maybe something's wrong with them
because now I just feel like there's
something all these schools not telling
us do you think they don't like it's not
because he's Asian what if he goes to
the interview and they're like man you
seem perverted but they don't want to
say that you know what I mean
[Music]
as somebody who has been an amazing
overachiever in lots of different things
I think you'd have a really good opinion
on this the rest of us can't really
speak fruit I'll shut the [__] up um so
there's this kid he's 18 Chinese
American from Florida
he scored a 15-90 out of 1600 on his
SATs wow so it's like near perfect yeah
graduated lots of f in a Chinese mom's
eyes
what happened that last question our
family his his GPA out of high school
was
4.65 Jesus Christ
um I didn't even know that was possible
it is with enough like if all your
courses are AP and you have like extra
because you know APS are worth more I
bet you his mom is like why didn't you
graduate college at 14 like these other
Geniuses
why you're not like Smart Guys
yeah so um his name's John Wang oh my
God that's even he's every Asian
parent's dream right he applied to MIT
Caltech Princeton Harvard Carnegie
Mellon and UC Berkeley all of which
denied his entry is it because his GPS
too high was he missing I bet you it's
because you ain't got no personality you
[__] boring ass asian
that's what they said you know what I
think it is I think it's there's so many
Asians applying if it's not perfect it's
not work you can't get in it's too
competitive what's more perfect than
that though damn that's pretty perfect
yeah man who [__] Nails the SAT like
that didn't he sue him or some [__] or
what'd he do he's uh they're not suing
but he is trying to he is trying to uh
find out what happened finally uh
declare that it is on the grounds of
affirmative action you know how like a
lot of that happened to a lot of Asians
where they felt like oh you just don't
want your school to be all Chinese
because if it yeah if it was fair by
score yeah it brought me pretty Chinese
because they actually do that yeah he's
Chinese American though but now there's
a now there's a law saying that no
University can uh can tailor their
admissions based on race yeah that's
crazy that includes both directions it's
like you can't have you know none of
someone and you can't have all of
someone yeah I say when it gets to that
level if you [__] made it there and
you are that type I'm we're taking your
ass
the hill yeah what's the why wouldn't
you want to take him come on bro and I
was on his record you got cousins you
got a little brother
we'll do a feeder program come on man I
think the first thing people ask is like
do you have any extracurriculars do you
have any other things that are like
makes you a worldly human being but like
it also depends on what he wants to
major in I think he wants to do
engineering yeah let him in
oh yeah
yeah but he's one of ours he's a Chinese
American so I do know that when they
look at
um applicants it's not always grades
right like they look at what did you do
for community service that's like a big
thing yeah right dude they don't look at
that [__] you think they do what kind of
community bro when you're nailing school
is hard what kind of community service
you got time for
that's true trash pickup I'm just not
being a negative influence is probably a
good thing for the community that's true
yeah yeah that's a fair argument baby is
that crazy that's a good point you're
just not being a jerk off and you just
you know mind your own business that's
that's good for the community no yeah it
is yeah cookie sales car washes that's
what sectors at none of these schools
are are uh they're not liable to like
tell you the reason why you didn't get
it so it's kind of hard to like make
sense of why I'm getting into any of
them you can get in any of those what
about any Cal State instead of going to
Georgia Tech I mean he could get into
Cal State of course that's not what if
they denied the top of the top yeah he
wants higher education I thought Kel
Tech was good Caltech is good he didn't
get it in Caltech how are you not giving
the Caltech one before six yeah he tried
he that Caltech was one maybe
something's wrong with them because now
I just feel like there's something all
these schools are not telling us do you
think they don't like it's not because
he's Asian what if he goes to the
interview and they're like man you seem
perverted but they don't want to say
that you know what I mean
what are some traits that would make him
seem perverted in it what if his eyes
are too close together or something he
goes into being like
that's a discrimination [__] we can't
have this guy in here okay so it's let's
say you're not really counting what do
you think was in his letter that made it
seem like he was weird like what if he
talks about like like you know in the
section of like what kind of hobbies do
you have and he's like oh I go to the
mall and I take pictures of upskirts
what if he was what if it is what if it
is personal statement essay he just
would he would talk about a sister too
much and it was like a little creepy
like hey dude I think you're in love
with your sister
I don't know it's just something to
think about what if it's like he's a
little weird yeah Pat like they asked
him like what is your passion and he
goes like women and that's it
so it was something in his personal
statement I don't know that's the thing
you'll never really know but one thing's
for sure that at this stage of college
acceptance they're just looking at all
these Asian names and going yeah
obviously they all have good grades we
can't take them all I think that's
what's happening they're just like we
can't take all these guys yeah he should
have changed it to John Wayne John Wayne
with the Wayne yeah Wayne John Wayne's a
cool name yeah maybe you should have
just taken the G out and then changed
his last name to Wayne John Wayne and
then they would have been like oh I
think they did I can't I'm not sure if
I'm getting this wrong but I feel like
they did this like uh some kind of
algorithmic study where they he really
wanted to know like what happened with
my [__] so I think he plugged his GPA
and all of his require all of the things
on probabilities yeah on a probability
thing that like averaged all the
students that have like applied in their
GP or some [__] and it said that because
he was chinese-american he had like a 20
shot wow and then he they looked at like
if you were like a black American and
you had like an 80 or something and he
was not happy with that what let me
let's play devil advocate let's let's
just say for example
um
college for football or basketball a lot
of black athletes get accepted because
they are gifted in that in that aspect
one of the guys said hey we can't take
it because we already have too many
black athletes I think Sports is a great
uh symbol for like yeah if you're good
you're good you're good yeah yeah yeah
yeah if he's good [__] take him I was
true who gives a [__]
Polynesians yeah yeah are over
represented or something in in
um in football there's a lot of
Polynesians are over represented yeah oh
so no one's yeah like Tongan Samoans
Hawaiians yeah a lot of like small
population but a lot of them become
football athletes right but I think
that's true like good right if a lot of
Asians are mathletes you know because
math is athleticism too yeah like brains
we just make the mathlete team Chinese
well what if like let's say you have a
college like like uh hypothesis of like
Harvard for instance wanted to promote
diversity
don't they have to have a little less
Asians to do that I mean what so they
have to kind of in a way discriminate to
a degree to even fluctuate well they
still need people to [__] roll their
crew boats just put all the white people
on the blue boat team yep
I still need to do their [__] you get
the one person that says row yeah you
still need those guys he's playing
lacrosse can you imagine that all the
white guys play lacrosse all the Indian
dudes do spelling bee yeah yeah all the
black dudes play football
Chinese been Asians [__] dudes math
and [__] yeah it's simple simple aren't
these guys getting this wrong that way
you can still look diverse because you
still gotta Shuffle the cards in the
middle of the school yeah but then when
you go to the department you separate
them all
I never knew there was a thin line
between diversity and segregation all
right right no you just use everyone's
strengths for what they're good at but
what if you can't what if you have a
limited number of people you can take
then they better have real diversity
they better have like a dumbass in
Harvard they better have a dumbass how
many more Four Points one dumbass a year
candidates were there you know for him
yeah they need a 1.0 dude they need some
like maybe the way they I'm just
thinking possibly maybe the way they
look at it is past 4.0 you're already
pretty freaking smart and you're good
maybe like they want to see something
more oh I see a different direction and
not just one on top of the four can you
get like how high of a four point but I
thought those schools were all about
like old money just being like making
friends like I didn't know it was
because it's political another reason
why this kid might not be conducted well
enough for him to seem like an
attractive yeah it's like old money
Legacy Schools right so like all these
because I heard that if your
grandparents went and then your dad went
and then like it's like the alumni
system we all learned that from Fresh
Prince and then your family donated a
[__] ton like every year then it's like
it's just almost like you got the you
got that club yeah the bride or you
could just fake like you were a rower
like they did for uh what's what's that
girl's name oh yeah like they yeah the
Colleen's right like how many of those
are out there like this this is like an
anonymity I would taken I was like yeah
this this kid is a gym he's obviously a
genius one year he was just competing
with you know another
34.6 gpas which is just true they could
have just put them on the waiting list
so look if you're if you're on the fence
if you want to take this kid in you say
all right let's just put them on the
wait list and then we'll figure it out
Bring John Wang in here let him talk
either way Georgia Tech is lucky to have
this kid oh absolutely man yeah is that
the Bulldog that's Georgetown Hoyas
I don't think he wants to go there
[Music]